قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان السفينه
الحربيه الروسيه ايفان هورس تعرضت لهجوم
فاشل من قبل ثلاثه زوارق مسيره اوكرانيه
في البحر الاسود عند اقترابها من مضيق
البوسفور وقال المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ايغور
ان السفينه الحربيه كانت تحمي خطي انابيب
الغاز تركستريم الذين ينقلان الغاز من
روسيا الى تركيا جزئيا عبر البحر الاسود
وانها استمرت في اداء مهامها بعد الهجوم
واكدك ناشينكوف تدميرا جميع المسيرات
المائيه التي هاجمت السفينه على بعد 140
كيلومترا شمال شرقي البوسفور
من موسكو مع مدير مكتب الجزيره زاور شاور
زاور ماذا في تفاصيل ما اعلنت توموسكو من
تعرض احدى سفنها لهجوم اوكرانيا
نعم ايمان مساء الخير
سفينه الاستطلاع ايفان خورس وهي احدى اهم
السفن في اصول البحر الاسود من الناحيه
العمليه عملياتها تعرضت بحسب بيان وزاره
الدفاع في الساعه الخامسه والنصف تقريبا
بتوقيت موسكو نفسه توقيت ايضا اسطنبول
لهجوم بثلاث مسيرات مائيه هي عباره عن
قوارب سريعه ملغمه يتم التحكم بها عن بعد
يعني يجري استخدامها بشكل مشابه تماما
تقريبا
للمسيرات الجويه ولكن هي تسير على
سطح المياه وانه تم استهدافها في المياه
الاقتصاديه التركيه شمال شرق
مضيق
الباسورد على بعد تقريبا مئه واربعين كيلو
مترا من هناك بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تم تدمير تلك المسيرات المائيه ثلاث وطبعا
كما قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع بان
الغرب الذي يدعم اوكرانيا يسعى الى تكرار
ما فعله الغرب في
بحر البلطيط تحديدا باستهدافه خط انابيب
نوت ستريم الاول والثاني للغاز الروسي
المتوجه لاوروبا بحد ذاتها هذه العمليه
ايمانيه تطور نوعي في المواجهه سيما وانها
ربما تكون بعيده عن ساحه الجبهه او خريطه
او جغرافيا المعركه في اوكرانيا انها جرت
في جنوب البحر الاسود قرب على راضيه تركيا
وليس في شمال البحر
الاسود عند السواحل الاوكرانيه وسيما وان
روسيا نبهت سابقا بانها رصدت محاولات حتى
لتلغيب خطيه انابيب الغاز الروسيا
المتوجهه المتوجهان الى تركيا هنا بدرجه
الاولى نتحدث عن عن خطين باربعه انابيب هو
خط التيار الازرق الذي يتوجه بالغاز
الروسي تحديدا الى تركيا وتستخدمه تركيا
وخط تركسترين الذي ينقل الغ از ايضا الى
غرب تركيا وتسعى روسيا مع تركيا كما نعلم
لانشاء مركز توزيع لالغاز الى القاره
الاوروبيه في اسطنبول شكرا لك
مدير مكتبنا من موسكو